alright guys we're here it's date fails
I think we're rolling I think we're on
we've started now four times the third
time we've done this podcast tonight
this is like all of the sex with
nevermind Oh with you who can we discuss
with so many old men that I've had such
fun I understand you've got a lot of old
men oh I aged that's not all buddy is
thirty how old are you
almost twenty-five twenty-five yes
twenty-five you know Hollywood are you
listening congratulations
hot 25 I hate aging I hate it so we're
not aging I am I just get Botox no I'm
totally aging I just had a birthday
happy birthday to you yeah she's also 25
yes I turned 25 again actually I just
say 27 forever now I am yeah 27 is my
age really yeah you look amazing you
look not a day over 25
you know why you still look 12 actually
you do look really young but it's partly
the glasses oh good they're hot they
hide my big feet they're so distracting
you can't see where I'm aging you guys
can't see her glasses unless you're
watching this on camera but they're
pretty obnoxious
Jessica's wearing I should prize say who
you are I'm Jessica Michelle singleton
and these glasses are mine I like they
just introduce yourself could you list
your own credits also could you give
yourself a full proper intro how I wish
I could I wish I was better at selling
myself I'd I'd be further in my career I
feel like you're everywhere like you
literally traveled the world like every
time I look at your Twitter you're like
I'm in Africa telling jokes I'm in Saudi
Arabia it's like you're everywhere I get
around I've heard that about you yeah
people say yeah no offense it's fine I
wish I got around I don't get around
anymore
what are you had sex in like 48 hours
how live you must be just dying I didn't
have birthdays sags I'll tell the story
but I didn't I had a date fail on my
birthday I'm depressed definitely that
was it the day before your birthday like
we saw you Monday oh that night too I
didn't have sex I haven't had sex this
week oh I haven't had sex in months
me too last time I had sex Jimmy Carter
was president so oh my god you're so oh
I know thank you
who's turned on now can we
man lover over here oh my god Jason
Tibble is here also from punch drunk
punch boat and 92 7 the pod both things
are on all things comedy here so please
enjoy those
yeah and just plug your pocket my
podcast is called ignorance is hashtag
blessed you guys it's just my own
free-floating podcast I love it you have
one of my favorite Twitter's to your
Twitter is so funny
thank you you're one person I followed
everything you tweet I'm like I've
thought that like you you tweet the
things I think in my head all day that's
huge
I'm oversharing it's just like a
timeline of all my bipolar Evans cares I
just say whatever I want now I used to
like care and be like what if people get
mad about this or don't like this but
now I'm just like whatever you shouldn't
you can't filter it though the mini
start filtering I feel like is the
minute that you're gonna just lose your
edge as a comic - yeah that's not art if
you're just like trying to pander to
what people want to hear because that
changes that'll change and I don't want
to be the lady gaga yes I do I do - but
ladies she's amazing you don't want to
be the Justin Bieber I do she already
owns that thank you I appreciate that
oh let's just start with what we were
talking about me get out old Bieber moon
down can I give your dick a plug or not
ease go ahead oh my god wait I don't
even remember how this happened it give
me a black hello
this doesn't happen hello and but we
were at the parlor the other night how
did you end up showing dick pics team
how did this happen
yeah she said something about it was
something about my dick you were sure it
was me yeah sitting around it was me you
and like Jason rouse and Jason rouse I
think we're showing it's on your
Rawlings or something Jarnell Rawlings
I think Darnell asked to see it I'm
kidding imaginary show me your dick I
don't like okay sure you got it you know
what it was you were showing me other
photos in your phone and I said don't
scroll through to the nudes or something
yes somehow it came out and in there but
he has I gotta say not attend scale
a pretty good angle on his photo attend
on the dick he even showed me one where
it was not but what's what's it pin on
the deck for you
like are you into just like the bigger
the no it's not a size Queen situation
although yeah although that would be a
that would be a little large I would
thank ya know you ain't even want that
dick no it's like the size and the shape
and the color and the hair it's a whole
thing
thank you yeah it's just like a perfect
balance yeah I'm gonna get a yelp review
going for my dick everybody says too big
right I don't want it too big some
people do I don't want it too big either
I don't have a lot of room in there
you're I'm great for men who have like
average to slightly undersized penises
because it makes them feel really ma'am
that's a good thing I am I have a big
dick and like yeah that's what it is
it's not that I'm half a person you're
small you're a small lady creepy small I
always wondered that though it's the
vagina it's love in my medium dick
midgets actually midgets though have
normal-sized penis it's like how they
have giant heads or regular high size
heads but on tiny body exactly then I
think it looks even bigger don't drag on
the ground with their tiny little way
maybe we should call Brad Williams and
yeah yeah yeah I've actually randomly
seen Brad that's random it's like his
dick would just fall out he just pulls
it out at random I don't remember how I
saw his butt I saw his like check out my
dick guy I think it was something along
those lines drunk at a party for is like
curious I was like is it really but I've
heard it's big yeah I mean is it bigger
is it's like one of those weird optical
illusions yeah like a funhouse mirror
yeah right you can tell yes
awkward how many dicks I've seen and and
never ever touched like when I start
thinking about it I've seen a lot of
dick that I'm not really well I'm just
really also not touching than seeing
well I did you surprised you what does
you touch it now that it's out can I pet
it well I have to see what it looks like
jacob reward how would you feel if a guy
like let's talk about this for a minute
though all the guys now in the news
pulling they're calling their dicks out
and I started actually thinking back
like how many times
this happened to me that a guy is poor
to stick out without me asking and it's
happened a few times
yeah and I've never been like we're
always been like - seriously dude yeah
I've never been like in what time today
pull a dick out are you like making out
and like in it or is it just like where
we're watching TV and I look over and
he's got his out
that's hilarious there's like there's
different levels of why do you pull your
out all of a sudden like does a
scene in a movie just inspire it no it's
happened to me it's happened to me a
couple times in a place like a car or a
green room honestly a green room I
happen in a green room once but it was
with a comic I'm friends with yeah but I
think he just kind of thought like we'd
always had a flirty vibe but I need I've
ever been
we never kissed or hooked up and then
you know he was a little drunk and was
kind of it has Asperger's it's like well
just pull my dick out I mean it was one
of those yeah all right I don't know
does that ever really happen because men
who tried I did they're like well if I
just pull it out she won't be able to
contain or so it has nothing is further
from the truth
really have you ever pulled your dick
out honestly to see what was to see what
happened to someone I mean as a goof a
lot of times you know like I used to
like my used to live with a girl marry
today and I would always like trick her
to look at my duck I would open the
refrigerator door while she's on this
side of it and I'm telling my pants off
and then when I close the refrigerator
door I'm naked
that's so fun like that but I've
never been I had look what's going on
right here and slap my dick on a table
cross my fingers and hope she starts
wants to take it for a walk also like
with strangers it's so different from
with your friends like thought out it
like in a coffee bean like at the table
like over a meeting a business meeting I
mean thank God I don't have a dick
because I would be in so much trouble
but would you pull it out of you would I
would just think it's so funny like I
wish that my lives for a big
enough that I could just like hold him
out of like the zipper in my jeans just
to give anyone notice I'm glad they're
not
like a little oh so unattractive I
remember growing up like I would drive
around and pickup trucks I mean granted
I was a hick total like white trash
going up but I would drive around and
pickup trucks with my friends in the
back of a truck and moon everybody I was
such a big moon er right me too RunAs
gone away I street
I totally street now I've lost my body
confidence because of LA oh stop no I
was never streaking and being like look
how hot I am I was just like this is
holy body I have the body of like an
underfed like old man who escaped from a
mental institution or just like loose
and weird oh you've done such a good job
of underselling yourself that's what you
do is like I lower the bar so much the
people are like you know what bad as I
thought it would be that's a really good
plan nice that is great I really do I
don't understand why people put their
best photos on dating so pleasantly
surprised is that like I I don't even
use dating apps anymore because I'm just
like why what am i doing but like when I
did I was like you know what I'm gonna
put realistic photos and I was like
these are photos that actually look like
me but I was like because everyone does
the best photo thing I was like people
are looking at my photos and thinking
I'm even uglier they know cuz they're
gonna make this is the best she has
that's what I think you should put
photos that make you look a little
shittier than you really do I want to
make a dating app where all you can
write is your flaws like I know but I
want it to be like your but you can only
list things that are like perceived like
personality flaws about you and you
can't say anything else and then and
then right you read it and go can I
handle this it's like this person
do I find myself looking at them enough
like they're attractive element the fact
that you'll stab me or whatever good
point
I think guys though but it's like that
thing I used to do on tinder like I talk
about it on stage that used to go on
tinder and message guys and literally
act like a psycho and say like hey
I want to have a one-night stand but I
have a weird quirk where I like to bring
leeches in bed and like put them on like
okay yeah guys would be like oh yeah
they don't care they're so
disgusting thank you
right here I'm sitting
right here another one right over there
there's another one right over there
he's an angel guys are disgusting but I
mean we know it we still then we still
are like I'm gonna put this in my mouth
ooh every woman thinks it like the man
that they're with like when you start
dating someone you're like like mineral
gross and then you start dating
one you're like he's gross
it's like you think it's cute like I
don't know the thing about all the
things that turn women on about men at
the beginning like the reason you're
attracted to them are the things that
you end up writing about like you go
like that's the same for us for about
you though it is sure yeah you're like
her perfect tits yeah exactly
no but like uh women will be like I love
these like so flirty and he's like I
don't know he's so funny when he tags in
the comments whatever and then you're
like can't you just be real for five
minutes
yeah god he won't stop texting me Jesus
Christ never really said that about any
I'm always the one that won't stop
texting guys I have to respond to
everyone
it's like compulsive I get so mad this
is the thing I'm not a crazy person like
I'm not the classic being a crazy person
every crazy I'm not crazy I'm never
jealous no it's like I'm not crazy right
here well I never I don't show up like I
won't show up at your house I don't
stalk social media I'm I'm very good
about all that like don't be a psycho
like the bio one I am like this if
we're on the regular and you
don't answer my texts for a reasonable
amount of time which to me is like 3-4
hours yeah there's nothing you're doing
I don't care where you all can't even be
like hey busy but I'll text you later
thank you so to me if you don't do that
I get so crazy
oh you got to be like hey sorry I didn't
text back I was asleep or something like
that any like okay cool say that's why I
haven't hit you up yeah I'll go crazy
when I'm talking to a guy and then all
of a sudden he's not texting back and I
think you make this whole scenario no my
head I'm like oh he's probably just
talking to some other woman I guess he
didn't even like her yeah we do the same
you do absolutely totally of course
you care you care thank you this is I
just got in a fight with someone about
this a few weeks ago because we're in
the middle of a conversation yeah and it
was a conversation I didn't even want to
have I don't think you should have any
conversation over text that's like
anything but flirting yeah but it was
like he brought up like another guy and
asked me if I had like hooked up with
this guy I'm talking about it then to
ask you at all but be right and we
weren't exclusive
it's none of your business but
then that thing is in the middle of is
it oh stop wait not wait hang on he was
asking you if you hooked up something
other guy it was a guy that a friend a
mutual friend of yours no it's a guy
that a guy I was seeing not exclusively
but regularly and then there's another
guy I'm friends with that he knows I
hang with and he was like I don't get it
you guys just hang but you've never
fought and then I was like well we kind
of hooked up a little but we didn't
but we kind of fooled around and then I
wasn't that into him and he was like
well what exactly did you do oh right
and then I was like I I was like what's
the big deal why does it matter and then
all of a sudden he just didn't answer
back all of a sudden for three hours
what right thank you and then he's in
the middle of saying all this and then I
start getting crazy like hey did I say
hey are you pissed where'd you go didn't
like I keep texting every like half hour
after that because now in my head I'm
like I'm thinking I up or why did
he suddenly wait I'm allowed to hook up
with people I was yeah yeah yeah yeah
but then I was just like maybe I and
even now if we weren't together so then
I was like maybe I said the wrong thing
and then finally when he answered later
he was like all pissed off that I was
blowing him up and he didn't understand
why I went crazy and I go if I'm in the
middle of talking to someone he's like I
walked into a business meeting I'm like
first of all no one's an
meaning for three hours I don't care
what kind of meeting you're anything
like you could have said going into a
meeting that was my thing that's that's
what you do don't you just say like oh
hey I'm about to walk into a meeting so
I gotta hit you later million percent of
thank you I know I'm not crazy yeah also
wherever you are you're not that
talented no nuts to hang out you that
long you're a hack is that the same one
we were talking about yes but I'm so
proud of myself because he texts me oh
so the hacks dude the hit
the fan because he wouldn't come to my
birthday party we got in the hugest
fight about this and I was like then
it's done if you want my birthday party
it's done right I mean you can
show up that's what I said do what you
did come through and give me a hug and
leave no he's you come through
and buy you all the drinks and like be
so grateful that he even has ever gotten
to see you naked how about this pick up
the check for all my friends you're a
millionaire this guy yeah what a
pity he's a you you hack okay
we're done Eddie Murphy Norbit sucks is
it Norbit norborne Norbit all the
different fat people I mean no to keep
it off before you were talking about it
you're like I'm not gonna take this off
because you fear you have bingo wings
she's like a hundred pounds
I'm 108 108 pounds she's a hundred a
pound she's like my arms wobble
understand how I can weigh so little and
still jiggles so much first of all you
don't jiggle but secondly you just might
be the barboza method I want to come
come I love that boy that looks a lot
that's a much better look for you she's
a tight-ass much like you're like I know
right oh those rafts from that coming
from Cuba with like 50 people on it like
can we just discuss that jessica is
wearing glasses that you've definitely
seen at a nursing home on senior citizen
and now she has her sweatshirt tied
around her not like a shawl well you're
fine my arthritis
you look amazing thank you single right
now by the way I'm so sick yeah you
haven't had sex in months you said you
need their teeth ah yeah me either
no sex for months yeah probably four ish
I won't break up and I've lost my
sexuality what I'm like aren't you so
warning Here I am
I'm losing my I've become I decided
the other day I'm like man something's
gonna something's gonna something's
gotta give
I hope you're jerking off I don't need
to hurt ya but it's still that after a
while that does nothing to come back it
is but like I can tell what I'm
ovulating that's because like that's the
only God I'm so horny the day before my
period no oh I think my periods coming
too because I should both call me the
day before your periods have you ever
been like like someone and I
mean not at the moment but like there's
someone you're having sex with and you
know you're gonna get your period and
you're like you're trying to try to
quill it away so that you can them
before it calm yes like I literally I
literally when my last period was coming
I was so horny I hadn't had sex and I
know this isn't long but which for me is
all ours no it's I'm a sex addict I'm
hey me too
I've always been like crazy sexual it's
with my like whole personal
identity I'm doing the exact same thing
I've always been and now I'm like not
really as much of either of those things
and I don't know who I am
you're not anxious I've been meditating
a lot and I'm much less how do you
meditate without masturbating I've never
been able to do that yeah I think that's
key I lay there and then this like the
guy's voice starts in and then the ocean
sound for the headspace guy he's like I
bet a lot of people do it or not I think
about it I bet that guy gets a lot of
people I just get relaxed and then when
I'm laying if I'm laying in bed still
and quiet which is where I meditate I
laid out in bad
and I put on the white noise thing and
then I turn on the YouTube meditation
guy and I can't help it it just happens
within the first like three minutes
no I but I'm not like that cartoon of
women masturbating where it's like
laying in a tub and there's flowers and
everything's peaceful or whatever you
know what I mean where there's a cartoon
of masturbating on a cloud like a like a
bunch of pillows we're just like I'm so
relaxed like when I mastered me I'm like
a gremlin and I'm having like a Rolodex
of fantasies going through my head
rolling through different men I want to
and then they're just like you're a
and I'm being it by myself
like why does this make me happy she's
so right it's only important that the
girl like wears like nice lingerie and
she sets herself
unlike those beautiful pillows like the
right position like who does that
anytime you have you even has that many
pillows I'm starting to get a lot of
pillows but this is not this is sound
like how much I'm leaning into being a
single lady is very nesting the other
day I like cocooned myself in the
pillows like it was a womb and I was
like this is a problem she managed to
behave I'm not joking I woke up the
other morning with my magic wand between
my legs like I was spooning it like how
do the vibrator they scare me oh my god
I saw when it I'm gonna give you I
turned it on ah it's you I have to use
it over it's so powerful I have to use
it over underwear I can't put it
directly against my it's one-horsepower
you can't use it too often it's I die
yeah you I don't put it inside me damn
but you can by attach they sell
attachments for it oh I just use my hand
and I don't turn anything but I think
sometimes I'm think I'm gonna get carpal
tunnel because it takes just a little
too long and I'm like you ever like
about to and then your hands about
to give out and you're like god damn
it's like having a boyfriend who can't
keep his dick card you like please not
yeah I'm almost there
oh my god I mean I actually switched to
my hand recently because I was afraid
magic wand because they sensitize you
now is it too often I had a flashlight
and I you ever use one of those become
holy let me tell you that I had to
get rid of it after like about I had it
for months for months which one did you
have was it a nice girls come and you
couldn't clean it no that's the thing
that it's great I swear to god it's
better than jerking off no wait it's
better than Turkey absolutely huh it's
like sex flashlight Wow
everything else
it's an no it's better than or ad
oh absolutely better than a bad board
they gave them your K the stamina the
flashlight stamina training unit well I
tell you what after a while I could I
started getting get feelings for it I'll
be talking to it and serious no but
I did kind of start to like I I didn't
you have any need to talk to women
anymore
you're like like after a while I was
like man I'm gonna try to rap to this
girl when I just go home and my
flush like I feel like they're just like
I can just masturbate and the worst
thing about that is that it's like once
you're done it's so humiliating because
now there's dishes to do you put it in
the dishwasher with other dishes no no I
should get a new one a new flashlight I
got rid of it a long time ago years ago
years ago I literally had like when I
threw it in the dumps I just looked at
like I'm gonna miss you single tear yeah
that thing was incredible I'll never let
go
interesting talk we just had yeah okay
have you ever masturbated yes all the
time a fantasy of someone who you want
to have sex with that you bit like yeah
he's a legitimate person or oh and then
you actually them and you're like
boy so disappointed oh yeah yes of
course I'm trying to remember the last
guy that that happened with that oh we
had so much built-up tension I thought
it was going to be
and then we and he was so bad and
bad by the way this guy didn't eat put I
can't stand when guys don't eat I
I think if you don't eat you're
gay 100% gay yeah do you eat every
time oh absolutely
is your dick hit hard when you eat the
of course I write usually before
that guy who's usually about for that
who whose dick wouldn't get hard when
you went down on me
then he's gay and I was like I'm telling
you I told him it was weird he's gay
he's like all men are like that I'm like
no they're not like listen and but then
I was like maybe my just stinks
but like well this thing never bothered
anyone he opposed has been going dude if
a guy doesn't get off getting you off
that's not a guy I wanna well of
course you don't yep you do not want to
be with that person no the best guys in
bed get I love God it's usually
sociopaths by the way but listen so look
what I've done
yeah they're so good in bed that they're
so self-centered that they get off and
more on how many times yes I love
guys that like have a
competition going with himself for how
many times they can get you off their
guys like that sure I hate that I
realized I was attracted to that when I
was getting by a guy who was like
clearly a murderer like I'm he was I was
like my favortie talking to me but it
was this weird like perfect enunciation
and I was like wow this is like for you
and then I was like oh no I like it
no wait he was dirt like if he dirty
talked you with bad grammar then he's
like oh no I don't it was like the most
psychotic thing that his like
enunciation and grammar was perfect and
I was like oh no this is the thing I was
gonna be into that is a little baby I'm
a psycho yeah did he use like medical
terminology like did he say things like
vulva labia ya know what if he had oh I
would cry I can nearly feel my my erect
penis in your fallopian tube that turned
me on just now I kind of got me too
squirted just now there's no time oh you
tell us your birthday date for your
birthday date fail oh my god yeah okay
so check this out this is actually like
cool and weird there's a guy
I love you yeah there's a god an animal
so there's a guy but I want to beat off
to that I crazy he was throwing
his trash on the floor that's I love
trash also only litter all right they
say it's depressing but I'm gonna tell
it anyway that's a president so my
birthday was awesome you stop by my
party I have my saddle ranch you looked
amazing oh you're so sweet thank you I
was trying to write find the right
combination of like sexy but cowgirl so
I killed it latex with cowboy boots it
was fun I was like that top it was so
amazing thank you it was a bodysuit I
was obsessed with it I never wore it
before as a fashionista where it's - I
don't have any good clothes like it so
many in the 1950s in a convertible yeah
don't even stop you're stunning all
right so here's what happened there's a
guy I used to date okay we all know this
guy so now this is I don't know anything
I'm trying know him but I know who they
are
the night I met him this is so fun okay
I'll tell you after so do I know this
burger yeah okay he's a comedian okay
I met him years ago I think I was like
40s I Jim Gaffigan for years no
this guy's a comedian I think I've met
him like four or five years ago a long
time ago and we dated for a little bit
not exclusively but we dated for a
little bit and it was one of those when
I describe my relationship with this guy
like the gone girl couple like we were
you have you ever dated someone where
like you're psycho tops they're psycho
then they top yours that and you we just
were like programming out-crazy each
other remember earlier when I said I've
never shown up at a guy's house or
stalking right no he's the only guy ever
in my life that one time I showed up at
his house in the middle of the night one
time he shot I better not say this one
he'll kill me one time he punched a hole
in a wall he called the police on me I
got the police on him we rely
I had that exact I mostly just like the
craziest thing I do is like a strain of
text messages and then being like me too
why don't I just kill myself and then
two days later baby hey I'm really sorry
about that that's the craziest I've
done with any other guy this is the only
guy why'd you call the cops because he
showed up in my house once and wouldn't
leave it was never physical violence
yeah it was
like I couldn't get him to leave and
then once he couldn't get me to leave
like we would just get any screaming
fights and be like if you don't leave
I'm gonna call the cops and be like go
ahead call the cops tell fries
show up and like we would just like
scream each other love is beautiful
isn't it
you guys should have made love God the
sex was just like a huge piece of
that like oh yeah we were just like
hate sex oh dude that we had the hottest
sex from that was one guy that the sex
was built up like we went out I think
four or five times before we and
it took a while because we were both
like traveling and we kept missing each
other and when we finally it was
the best first sex it was like
right so anyway
Zach's also that gonna here's
psychological warfare on me because
after the sex he was like I want to play
this song for you and he played this
song which in hindsight I'm like I'm
begging you guys this to everyone no he
turned on a song and he played it in bad
and that song at the time wasn't very
popular but them became like a huge hit
and then every time we would like cuz we
would break up then them break up
them every time we break up and I'd hear
that song the radio I like start crying
or I get horny hit song is it it wasn't
John Legend was tell you this no okay
what if he does that to every girl he
probably does there's like eight girls
like who come every time they hear John
Legend or cry oh my god wait a minute I
think I bought them
no I listen to that song with the guy
once and later we had sex it just came
on the radio he wasn't playing it but I
cried during sex I was like I'm sorry
that song are you serious there's
nothing to do with you well alright so
long story short I know you the
same guy so weird
well I mean I've I'm you call me so much
widening circle it is we've all had sex
with Brenton yeah ours yeah yeah yeah
well he had sex with me I stated more
making that sounds like Brendon dude I
was dead unrelated but I was dating a
guy that I was kind of into and then I
found out one of my good friends also
dated him and I didn't know and had to
like I thought I was asking earlier when
you're talking about the guy asking
about your friend if you guys had hooked
up or not because there are people that
because our circles overlap so much
there are certain people that I found
out someone them you'd be like I
can yep exactly I'm not naming names but
there are people because they're friends
or because you're often discuss both
both both angles I see yeah you probably
have well like Sam Tripoli told me the
guy that I've been I told him
who it was and he said that I lowered
the value of my vagina that's funny I
was like what he goes used one from
platinum to Sterling
congratulations Trash Can would a
trash get it to my back to Sam and he's
my asking to look like that dog's ass I
was hooking up with this guy you know
there's a comic and like we've been
hooking up for a few months and I hadn't
told anyone because I just didn't tell
anyone I was taking my friend out to a
birthday dinner and she's like her
birthday lunch he's like oh I've been
dating this guy for a couple like him
and Isaac who is it and then she told me
I was like I've been that guy
for like ten months we're just both
crying over salads like I got so mad and
that's horrible I facetimed him and it's
like did you make sure to call and tell
her Burt because I told her right away
cuz it's like what do you just be quiet
about it no you mean people need to know
what I'm always very quiet when it's a
comic I actually think the girl should
tell each other because it's happened to
me twice that like a male comic has been
like really trying to step to me and
then another girl will tell me they're
dating him and then I'll say it right to
him like you can only date one of us at
a time yeah we all talk right
like it's okay to date another comic
people can't do it at the same time you
can't two female comedians at once
there's only like 20 of us and
gonna talk to each other over brunch on
Sundays we do it every week yeah there's
a secret brunch when we talk about an
idiot I'd love to go to that secret
brunch um shut up loser secret brunch
so anyway I lose back to the date so
this guy hack then we didn't know
different different guy this is I have
this guy so this is the ex guy that the
police call sure yeah uh-huh and he's at
your birthday party eventually we became
badges eventually became friends I mean
it took yours though we hated each other
even a good friend though are you like I
can't stand you um no I actually like
loved him now because I I love him
actually more now because I like get him
I see his damn he's a loving he's got a
good heart yeah both we're just not
up together we're to be Gideon
yeah when you're too much like someone
it's like fiery sex and a terrible idea
for a relationship yeah so probably but
I care about him he's a guy he's a guy I
can't date but I know like if I crash my
car and it caught him he'd show up like
you know yeah you it yeah she
would he really would but so the point
is we finally became like cool again and
every once in a while we'll every
once in a while but it's so different
now there's no feelings it's like and
it'll be like 2:00 a.m. he'll text me
drunk or I'll text him drunk it's always
when I'm sad about another guy or I'm
going through something and then I'll
come over and we'll have this amazing
sex and then I'll leave you guys are
gonna end up married I don't think so
but pointed Brian a very violent
domestic dispute that gets a lot of
attention from TMZ could happen but the
point is I invited my birthday party
I've invited him to a million things he
always says he'll come and he never does
so I was positive he wouldn't come
yeah and then he showed up and
you know I was like in my head I was
like I can't I couldn't believe he came
it was like the my was so touched that
he came and he stayed the whole night oh
my god all flirty and attentive right
right the whole night but here's the
thing so the whole night he's all like
flirty am i awesome I him tonight
what great birthdays I got to go not
even I come up to him love to somebody
else I don't know I was guessing we
won't let her see us the podcast he has
AIDS
no I said I go up to him and I'm like
I'm gonna get out of here student I'm
getting really tired and you like yeah
cool um and then I go I'm gonna go the
bathroom I go to the bathroom
I come out he's gone oh my god he's like
my dad I was so confused what if he what
if he was like I actually just came here
for karaoke I forgot the weirdest I
really was like so confused so then I
text him but here's the thing baby he
thought you left when you went to the
bathroom I I know him so well I do like
put it down like pretty like was it
known that you're like get out of here
tired I'm tired I'm gonna go to the
bathroom and leave no but the night
before my birthday I saw him at a
holiday party and we made out and it was
very like we like we should again
soon it's been a minute and then that
night he was trying to hit me up to
it but I couldn't because I had a early
morning and whatever so it was like
definitely like out there in the ether
and he was flirty you know and and like
but the thing is I know him so well that
when he gets a little too up
sometimes he just gets Spacey and he
just runs I think he just got you away
some birthday dude
that fool so that I was texting him like
where'd you go I just assumed you want
to someone else to be honest which
I don't even care like that's what's
weird I don't have feelings anymore at
all
no maybe you're dead inside I don't
think I can without feelings
anymore I can him without feelings
maybe that might be my thing you can't
without feeling I don't know I I'm
going through something similar that
you're going through like horny for
intimacy see that's what the governor
make eye contact and be like you're a
beautiful human in the universe
yeah but also like you but
like feel connected yeah you winter cake
and eat it too yeah I want to have my
cake and then I'm gonna it and eat
it and have it tell me that I'm not
really a after it called me a
huh as it holds me in bed Oh like
one of those I want the intimacy and the
part I'm with you oh yeah well you
know it's weird about me called a
but then afterward reassured that's like
you know really a for the time
fellow talk
talking of a dog yeah but I'm the same
way I love to be called a Matt you
dirty little it's like I want to
be clear I'm not really a
also when a guy text it to me like if
we're dirty texting and then he's like
you're such a and then I'm funded
doesn't translate well in text things
just sarcasm as well on taxes oh god
well but the point is that the guy texts
me back the next day and said like I was
so up I just I just left with my
buddy I wasn't even thinking he's like
but let's hook up this weekend so I mean
like we will I know we will
sure but what's weird is with him I
always sleep over
we always cuddle she's the only guy can
cuddle you guys are gonna not range for
how we really Wang the pressure is off
but he's are you scared why are you
scared he's gonna trick you and trap you
with his weenie who knows wait wait how
did you meet this guy I met him at a
birthday party of a friend was it mine
no you walked into saddle ranch and and
after there you are it was on the boy
like look at him ride that bull he could
ride this the John Legend oh yeah
that's what happened no I was at um
Dana's birthday party wait a minute is
it the guy that her mom brought wait a
minute her mom somebody brought her guy
as a gift which by the way is Louis Cole
it's some French man Jonathan kite
brought me to what happened someone
brought a guy like in a ball Dana this
is my gift about his dick she bounced
off never bow on it like a new Mercedes
right yeah Oh God that story is that guy
is it the guy is it some guy I was just
talking to you there that Dana's drunk
mom actually was like Oh who's your
introduce me to her boyfriend I was like
when I'd been talking to her for like
two minutes and was like oh he's not my
boyfriend and Dana's drunk mom is like
I'm getting like a vibe here and I was
like okay him drunk Ellen no way
but anyways I have a date with him I
don't know I'm scared where you guys
gonna go I'm not telling you
why is won't be until tomorrow
somewhere I don't really know I'd like
I'm gonna show up at your day sex
tonight at Dana's did a night of Dana's
birthday party with a guy I never slept
with before and really why was he at
Dana's birthday what if I'm gonna do the
same it's not the same guy don't think
probably it could be if it is I hope it
is because he was the he was in the top
five sex of my life
twenty was an animal
oh so I'm mentally handicapped looking
UFC fighters that were there that didn't
have an axe you can't say all right just
kidding
I had a nightmare happen to me we're
watching this here one of those guys I
was just kidding you seemed very smart
I I was talking to this girl last night
these guys will you like dumb
animals Oh dumb guys big dumb guys yeah
boy I will say that fighter said I have
hooked up with some fighters and it is
like they're like I mean they
fight like you get a matter UFC fighters
they're like just the grapple you and I
get it like it's like you dad want
someone to me like I hurt their
family hey they're looking for their
long-lost something inside my there's
some female fighters out out hook up
with some of the female - besides Ronda
Rousey oh yeah she's hot there's no
quite a few one better they're hot plus
it's sexy to me knowing that a chick
knows how to take a punch I just put
that out there I was talking to a girl
last night this is the worst kind of
going okay poor really cute and she's
like guess how old I guess how old I am
oh why would you say that he said that
and I was like 70 I didn't know no I was
like maybe like 30 21 already out I'm
already out did you check her ID now now
but just the fact that she's 21 and then
she gets how old I am guess how old I am
and she guesses 40 I was at 45 and she
goes on my dad's 43 Wow like I couldn't
holy he wanted if that was Oh bad
but worse she went to you so
get it I like holder right yeah
that's the only reason I think I like
older guys and I've only
like two old daddy what's the oldest guy
you fogged 6352
how old were you at the time that's a
great body over that time yeah last year
okay oh the biggest age gap that should
be the question right my biggest age gap
was let me see how old was I that was my
biggest age gap I don't even know like
17 or 18 years Wow I don't even know if
I've ever slept anybody older than me
maybe 20 yeah I don't know if I have I
mean same age maybe a year older than me
but for the most part now why would you
not a 21 year old
I mean I'd her what I mean I
wouldn't love her I would there's just
nothing we could have in common yeah
yeah yeah we're right what am I to do
with a 21 year old there's no way like
late 30s and someone in like their 50s
didn't do that the older both people get
the less weird the age she was pretty
mature for her age I never would have
guessed it was someone but we were
taught with talk for like an hour and a
half yeah and the minute she told me she
was 21
everything in me that was remotely like
your everything that's so weird though
after an hour and a half conversation
I mean you if you could talk to anyone
for an hour and a half I'm impressed
yeah but I mean no I was just out
there's not many people I can talk to
for more than an hour really talk to
someone for more yeah well you gotta
imagine if you talk to like the bagger
at Ralph's for an hour I can't do that
for like no offense to the baggers at
Ralph's I know so thank you I don't like
saying like regular people civilians
yeah people have like who don't want to
talk about anything deep or like really
interesting all right
I love like intense coming to you to me
to copy is just like let's get intimate
I'm saying yeah yeah we should do this
every day
I could I could just talk for the rest
of my life well we just did it podcasts
are great for us yeah for comics yeah
because we like to hear our own board
cast called deep talk seeped ah there's
so many podcasts going just call it
bingo wings we're almost out of time
wagging your you guys listening at home
you got to go check out the videos you
can watch Jessica my shakers on camera
or even jiggle follow me at bingo wings
on Instagram and it should just be all
ladies yeah someone painted I don't
remember when this was but someone was
one with an American flag
I saw that she waved her arms calls that
her wattle
my grandma had a gobble gobble
don't like the neck fat neck I'm getting
that I'm afraid of that because I have a
really small I've got like inbred
I'm afraid the wheels just fall off the
bus I call this I don't like you hit a
certain age and it just all of it goes
yeah it does the wheels are gonna fall
off but you're a guy luckily so guys got
hot over the age yeah men are just like
old and mysterious yeah we're just like
buoys so oh there's always a 21 year old
heavy tie yeah but like I bet his balls
hang by his knees so hot that's sexy
that's so hot do you guys have anything
you want to plug coming up I'll be I'll
be in Honolulu mom January 24th at Anna
O'Brien's but but listen to my podcast
ignorance is blessed yeah love it I will
be in st. Louis at helium comedy club
with Steve Rannazzisi January 18th 19th
and 20th anybody's and that neck of
woods wants to come see that and check
out my new podcast 92.7 the pod second
episode comes out tomorrow and it is
fake morning radio about a fake City Oh
Oh check that out and as always
punch-drunk on all things comedy as well
and guys I will be at the Las Vegas
Laugh Factory December 27th through
January 1st I believe for New Year's
it's gonna be so fun with da Moreira so
make sure you guys come out does that
check out my patreon if you haven't
patreon comback slash Kate cue funny you
can buy Jessica's dirty underwear so oh
my god she poops in it though yeah it's
all my own patriotic show many poopy on
all your poopy pants people I've made a
lot of money I think you could you
really could and I have I just have like
so many underwear filled with poo pee
stains I keep mine too I just collect
them in a bags good that's what like a
lot of women don't shave their legs on
the first day because I did wanna be
I were poopy underwear and it
likes piss off so this will keep me
straight I didn't shave my legs the
night of Dana's party because I didn't
want to that guy and then when I
got him back to my house I ran in the
bathroom real quick I was like I just
need a few minutes and I shaved like so
fast and it really
I cut myself like eight times and
bleeding he was like turn the lights off
and then afterwards I was like I'm not
on my period I cut myself shaving yeah I
had to tell them oh my god I was blood I
just always end up being like well I
guess he's just gonna remember me as a
girl with viciously hairy legs cuz I
couldn't not him yeah guys this has
been Dave fails we love you make sure
you follow us all and we'll see you next
time
clap it okay bye